[Music]
shakespeare was the creator of mass
entertainment
he was interested in reaching a very
large number of people in his world
and he
thought
professionally about how to reach those
people where they lived as it were in
their deepest way
i've thought about shakespeare for many
many years and i remain amazed
by his intuitive
ideas as to where the power would lie he
thought in
merchant of venice
about
the relationship between those who were
in the inside and those who were on the
outside between those who are
comfortably at the center and those who
are the pariahs the hated and spat upon
ones he looked for example to
uh women who didn't obey the rules as in
taming of the shrew
he looked to the relationship between
whites and blacks
and to thinking about sex anxieties in
othello he thought about what to do with
very old people
in families as in king lear he had what
seems to
us at this distance 400 years later to
be on an airing instinct for thinking
about what might still concern us even
though our concerns
are
quite different from those that governed
shakespeare's time and that's part of
the secret of his work he was a master
of metamorphosis he allowed his plays to
go out into the world and change their
meanings
and 400 years from now
though we can scarcely imagine what the
world will be like
i think we can be confident that there
will be people
many many people who will still respond
in their own ways
to what shakespeare
left them
this is part of the mystery
and part of the thrill of shakespeare's
work
[Music]
you